if you're an Arts student in the US
listen up because I got a 3D challenge
to fill you in on I'm teaming up with LG
this year as a judge in their LG
wonderbox showcase where we're
challenging art students across the
nation to create cool 3D art for LG's
Corner screen in Time Square myself and
a small panel of Judges will select the
top three and I'll see you in New York
you're going to walk away with thousands
of dollars like honestly it's ridiculous
first place gets 25k second and third
place get cash prizes as well really the
whole thing is a hoot we did it last
year it was fantastic and I'm happy to
be back doing it this year so if this
sounds like fun to you guys and you
think you got what it takes then do what
you do best and have fun making art
around the theme of Life's good with
optimism over the next couple weeks the
challenge ends November 20th and I am
super stoked to see you in New York's
Time Square on December 7th so get to it
and get started by clicking that link
down below